Hey youtubers it’s charlie, here’s my
arrow Q&A as promised.
A lot of you had questions about the suicide
squad as well as the league of assassins and
rash al ghul.
So I picked 10 of the most interesting ones
to answer in this video.
Also heads up, if you didn’t see already.
I’m doing a bunch of big videos for the
superbowl trailers tomorrow.
Including Days of Future Past and Captain
America The Winter Soldier.
Be sure to subscribe to get those.
Everybody grab your mirakuru cocktails and
let’s get started.
Question 1 Reza zarabi (no avatar) asks Who
else will join the suicide squad this season
or is it possible that amanda already recruited
some members before bronze tiger and deadshot.
I think that we won’t see the squad again
till season 3.
Meaning they’ll cast some new people.
It’s possible they could cameo again during
the finale.
But probably not.
When they do come back I’d look to the other
B-level villains like Yo-yo, voltaic, black
spider, maybe cheetah.
Bet on them keeping the roster small though.
They won’t cast too many new people.
Question 2 Ian Resham (no avatar) asks do
you think the mirakuru derived from the lazarus
pit seeing as to how they both share some
similar properties and side effects....do
you think this might be revealed in the next
episode?
No, I think the only reason the league is
in starling city is because of Merlin and
the canary.
The mirakuru is closer to DC’s version of
the marvel super soldier serum.
People on it aren’t immortal.
It’s just a less crazy version of Bane’s
venom.
Question 3 Kennymiranda97 (no avatar) asks
Will they introduce slades daughter?
You’re talking about Ravager.
I can’t remember if they mentioned her during
season 1.
Maybe briefly.
But his son was just mentioned last week.
So he would be the first one to come on the
show.
I haven’t seen any casting announcements
for the character, but it could totally happen
in season 3.
Question 4 Adam Norpchen asks What other main
dc supers do you think
arrow with have? in the far and near future?﻿
Question 5 - tekkenMaster87 asks Do your think
by the end of season 2 or the beginning of
season 3 will we ever see ras al ghul?
No major super heroes.
But definitely some B and C Level heroes.
The flash is the only other major super hero
we’ll see.
And he’ll probably get a cameo or two this
fall when his tv show debuts.
Just to build some excitement.
Question 6 Isaias Mazariego (no avatar) asks
Do you think The Flash Tv Show is going to
introduce different Flashes like Wally West
or Kid Flash to help Barry Allen using time
travel via speed force?
And any idea on when The Flash tv show will
start?
Good question.
They haven’t announced anything yet.
But I don’t think they’ll do that in season
1.
They’ll include references like when they
use names from the dc universe as street names
in arrow.
But if they ever do have another version of
the flash it would probably only be after
the first couple of seasons.
Season 1 will be all about developing grant
gustin’s character.
Once he’s established, then there might
be room for some other flashes.
It also depends on how close to the new 52
storyline they’ll stick.
Question 7 Henry Lh asks Did you notice the
guy that left the bar just after Laurel did?
Do you think that he was a member of the league
of assassins?﻿
Yes, they’ll probably follow up with that
next week.
Sarah will probably kick his ass.
Question 8 Lizabeth90 (no avatar) asks Do
you think that slade will make Oliver relive
the scenario of Shadows death only this time
with Laurel & Sarah
You mean like make him decide who to kill.
I think it’s possible.
There is a rumor that Sarah will die this
season and laurel will become black canary.
So that could be how that happens.
But I’m not expecting a laurel version black
canary anytime soon.
Question 9 JasonCheeeseball asks Is Amanda
Waller good or bad?
She was the one behind the planned destruction
of china's economy and is now hiring mercenaries
to form the suicide squad?
Yet she wanted to help diggle find lyla .
Amanda Waller has always been an antagonist
to the justice league.
She technically works for the government.
So she will usually do whatever it takes to
fix a problem, including putting superheroes
lives at risk.
Which is kind of what the suicide squad is
all about.
She’s like a shotgun spray shooting supers
at problems, hoping that they fix it or die
trying.
Question 10 Nam Harper asks Hi.
Do you think that Thea could go Dark side
after learning who is her biological father?﻿
I think that by the end of the season all
the characters will return to their normal
relationships.
But I do think that Merlin will be able to
twist Thea around a little until the league
of assassins gets involved.
Don’t be surprised if Thea’s life is put
at risk by the league as a way to lure merlin
out.
Bonus Question Mobbmaster asks do you think
Batman and Superman will be mentioned or make
cameos in the show?
Do you think The future Justice league movie
will include a new oliver queen, or Stephen
Amell?﻿
Definitely not on superman/batman.
They’re just too big.
It’s stephen amell’s show.
There will never be an actor or character
more important than him on the show.
And Stephen Amell himself actually said that
he was not approached at all about Justice
League.
It’s more likely that they just wouldn’t
use the green arrow character at all and it
would just be batman, superman and wonderwoman.
Think of justice league like a trinity storyline
if you’ve read the comic books.
You can only cram so many big characters into
a movie before it turns into spiderman 3.
Amell did say that he was totally down to
make an Arrow movie though.
So it’s totally possible that they would
turn a two hour long episode into a tv movie
after the show’s final season.
But that probably won’t be for several years.
Hint Hint, I’m expecting Arrow to get at
least 5 seasons, probably 7.
Thanks so much for submitting questions.
I hope I was able to answer some of the bigger
ones.
Don’t forget I’ll be doing a ton of super
bowl trailers this sunday and this week on
arrow nyssa al ghul is coming.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Right now click here for this week’s training
montage edition of arrow and click here to
learn all about jesse eisenberg becoming lex
luthor in superman vs batman.
Thanks for watching.
See you guys tonight.
High Fives!